I set a pretty high goals for myself
they're usually higher than what I think
most other people said from upset for me
and I just AM a I'm very driven to
achieve them I'm a goal oriented
individual and and i just am very driven
to achieve those goals and I'm not the
person who sets very high goal you don't
set high goals my goal post keeps on
changing as we move forward in the life
then you're not very disappointed if you
don't succeed it's always been one step
forward always make a small step forward
and you become stronger and to gain
confidence then you change your goal
posts so it gives you more pleasure than
setting up a very high goal and you
don't reach them I don't think we ever
talked i have over dad more than a year
ahead is that right last couple of years
we have been thinking more 58 strategy
or young you're just totally of those
days yeah the beginning we were looking
very short-term view my intention with
this video was just right understanding
not fighting I want you to see that it's
not one point of view or the other you
can pull and learn from both especially
the one that you don't immediately
resonate with embrace the genius of the
end